for the latest mini election trim I am
off to Glasgow for the SMP Spring
Conference party claims that this
conference is its biggest-ever with the
majority of those present being
first-time attendees members but did all
these new hands come from scottish
labour what are the pressing issues of
their mind what they think of having
their been a member sends the day after
the referendum us
I've had been in the labour party and I
was really disappointed with their
behavior at the referendum and I
realized he didn't have Scotland's best
interests at heart I was actually
involved with a radical independence
campaign using the referendum
so I'm kind of kind of finally sort of
got involved with a party and I was a
member previously for over 10 years let
it lapse on a couple of years but after
the referendum what he joined the game
yeah I don't have to send them
just a top station people I don't trust
the other person peerage their party
that don't talk down to you as the
people can lead the party and not the
other way around at all new to me
konstan i ever voted i voted with a look
of a whit of supporting John Smith the
only ever came over the first year 11 11
politicians then rejoice with died for
me the Liberal Party died i will topic
finally people like john smith in like
to leave and
I'll say like
even though you mean like Dennis Skinner
stole go back you know like old ethos
and sparrow of liver reported for
conservatives at times in the past I
think the number one biggest actually
business not learned with the debt to
know to NHS and nor spending 100 million
homes on trailer weapons
Westminster Parliament Westminster
doesn't listen to us
they're just rating off five and a half
and more million people
it's just chris to the milk the text
Navi storage people English people as a
voice base or the people of the UK and
westminister is the establishment a mess
the government system is not working
there's not the countries of the people
i think that they are corrupt adding the
remote I think they're self-serving and
they look after themselves and all the
people that they're veterans day I think
fish swims vicious rest of UK
spending west nestled steady because
their version of steady has in the
steady which could be settled in Europe
is violent and aggressive it doesn't
know social gain or economic income from
the end of I mean the fewer people the
disabled people the young people are
suffering from the mistakes of the rich
and they've been penalized while bankers
and rich people have not been penalized
we want to make sure we have all
Westminster speak to the fire what I'm
going to have to do in the general
election is get that MPs into
Westminster and the Scottish general
election push for the SNP ting even more
seats and Scarlett eventually get
independence maybe five ten years down
the line doesn't matter I'm really
optimistic or left applause you see well
we're coming up sexy and peace so if we
get seven then that's an increase
optimistically
everything is an achievable goal that
the one to do in Scotland at the moment
we're not taking the calls for granted
we log n completion for seeing is people
are actively enthusiastic about
important SNP and we're intending and
doing the best because smoke and all
goals are achievable at the moment I
think that the best in the end he can do
get into government with labour and push
the Labour Party to actually represent
the people that they're meant to
represent which is the working class and
the working people of the whole of the
UK and I think the SNP influence will be
good for the whole UK not just for
Scotland that's it for this mini
election adventure join me again soon to
find out how the election is being
fought in a different part of the
country find out more at mini election
co uk